[Música]
bueno
hoy me gustaría hablarles de ciencia
pero no de lo que la ciencia dice sino
de aquello que los científicos aún no
sabemos decir o mejor dicho de aquello
que aún no podemos o quizás no queremos
ver de nuestro punto ciego
la neurociencia tiene un conflicto de
intereses y la mayor parte del tiempo
aún sin declarar
un sujeto el científico estudia a otro
sujeto un humano un gusano una mosca un
ratón pero hace ver que su sujeto de
estudio es un objeto y que el propio
científico no está presente fíjense en
el truco empezamos con dos sujetos y
casi sin darnos cuenta por arte de magia
acabamos con un objeto
este conflicto de intereses tiene una
doble problemática en primer lugar está
el problema del observador el sujeto que
experimenta en segundo lugar el problema
de lo observado el sujeto sobre el que
se experimenta
bien el problema del observador nos
lleva al de la objetividad de si es
posible pronunciarse sobre la realidad
como algo que está ahí fuera
independiente de que la observa
pero no vemos el mundo como es vemos el
mundo como somos los físicos hace ahora
justo un siglo se toparon de frente con
este problema y descubrieron que la pura
objetividad es un mito
el observador no se puede dejar fuera de
la ecuación las demás ciencias han
resistido a esta revolución conceptual
casi sin modificar ni un ápice de su
abordaje que por otro lado sigue anclado
en la física del siglo 17
ignorar al observador no es algo que
podamos hacer o seguir haciendo
demasiado tiempo
ponerse una capa o una bata blanca no es
el objetivo no es desaparecer de la
escena la objetividad es algo que se
construye entre sujetos y esto nos lleva
al segundo problema el problema de lo
observado y éste concierne especialmente
a las ciencias de la vida y a las
ciencias de la mente incluidas claro
está la neurociencia y la psicología
entre otras y aquí nos encontramos con
la siguiente paradoja la biología
estudia la vida casi como si estuviera
muerta y la neurociencia estudia la
mente como si fuera un producto
anecdótico de la materia cerebral pero
yo me pregunto y les pregunto se puede
estudiar la vida matándola se puede
estudiar la mente desmontando la podemos
entenderlas
el amor no se puede reducir a un escáner
cerebral
y no encontrarán la humedad del agua
entre sus moléculas
la ciencia es parte de la vida no al
revés
este hábito que es casi un vicio de
pensar lo superior en términos de lo
inferior lo hemos heredado de la
biología molecular del siglo pasado
esa que afirma que la vida no es más que
bioquímica y que por ende la mente no
puede ser más que electroquímica
pero cada vez que oí a nadien decir que
no es nada más que be desconfían
no nos metamos por ahí ahora volvamos al
punto inicial a la idea que quiero
traerles hoy aquí para que la cuestión
hemos que tratamos a los sujetos como
objetos
aquí podemos echar mano de una idea
maravillosa a mí me encanta es la idea
de un belt que en alemán significa mundo
pero no cualquier mundo un mundo general
cualquier mundo no no es algo así como
el mundo dotado de significado para el
sujeto que lo experimenta el ambiente
lleno de significado pongamos un ejemplo
un árbol es un árbol pero un árbol para
una hormiga tiene muy poco que ver con
un árbol para un carpintero
para la hormiga es un refugio para el
carpintero probablemente una oportunidad
para hacer una mesa cada uno tiene su
umbert su mundo hay tantos mundos como
organismos vivos pues cada uno tiene su
particular forma de mirar al mundo
y esto nos lleva al siguiente
descubrimiento todos los organismos
comparten el mundo pero no todos los
organismos tienen el mismo mundo en
común
así cuando estudiamos en el laboratorio
el comportamiento de un ratón lo ponemos
en una cajita de un metro cuadrado lo
medimos muy bien durante cinco minutos
es muy probable que nuestro esfuerzo por
ser objetivos acabe siendo en el fondo
una proyección de nuestro mundo sobre el
del ratón y caigamos en una forma sutil
de antropomorfismo
hay un choque de mundos en nuestros
laboratorios
digamos pues al punto ciego de la
neurociencia
que es el de la percepción como dijo
morfeo en matrix el destino no está
carente de cierta ironía pues parece que
precisamente lo que la ciencia no
consigue percibir es la percepción misma
para abordar este problema pues no vengo
a traerles hoy una solución no la
tenemos permítanme que comparta con
ustedes nuestros esfuerzos
y lo hemos hecho con unos elementos un
tanto inesperados
combinando magia con inteligencia
artificial
ambos son unos espejos muy poderosos
para estudiar la percepción y la
cognición humana como verán y al mismo
tiempo representan un híbrido entre lo
nuevo y lo viejo pues la magia es un
arte milenario y la inteligencia
artificial una técnica relativamente
reciente y en empecemos por la magia
la magia es el arte de producir en el
espectador la experiencia de lo
imposible fíjense una cosa
es no saber cómo algo sucede y esto nos
pasa mucho a los científicos pero otra
distinta es creer que aquello que ha
sucedido no puede ser para el espectador
la ilusión es lo más real que hay pues
lo está percibiendo en primera persona y
de manera concreta aquí tienen un
ejemplo estos dos iconos en gris tienen
exactamente el mismo tono de gris
pero ustedes no lo perciben así verdad
es por el gradiente que está de contexto
que parecen verdaderamente los grises
distintos
de quien fiarse pues como dijo goethe y
lo dijo muy en serio la ilusión visual
es la realidad visual
además no hay magia sin espectador
el sujeto es el núcleo principal del
fenómeno mágico bien pues con miguel
ángel gea un mago profesional que por
cierto tiene su teatro muy cerca de aquí
el teatre encantado
diseñamos una serie de trucos muy
sencillos maniobras muy simplificadas
pero efectivas basándonos en su dominio
de la magia con monedas hacerlas
aparecer desaparecer cambiar de lugar
etcétera
en primer lugar lo que queríamos hacer
era medir con mucha precisión el
movimiento de sus manos en el juego de
manos para estudiar su destreza y cómo
su destreza nos consigue engañar y para
ello utilizamos un algoritmo de visión
por ordenador basado en inteligencia
artificial para explicarlo muy
brevemente
un humano le enseña a la máquina dada
una imagen un punto de interés por
ejemplo el dedo índice o una moneda clic
en la imagen y le dice esto máquina para
mí es el de oro tras unos pocos ejemplos
y esta es la gracia hay que entrenar
sólo con pocos ejemplos la máquina
extrae propiedades de los píxeles de la
imagen
en principio en futuras imágenes sabe
ver dónde estará el dedo o la moneda
aquí les muestro algunos de los
resultados
bien aquí miguel está haciendo algo
sobre los magos no tienen hacer que
repetir el mismo truco seguidamente
muchas veces claro está
nos lo permitió a continuación nuestra
idea fue enseñarle a la máquina no solo
a ver la moneda cuando está visible sino
a proponernos donde cree que está cuando
no está visible para eso recuerden que
la entrenas el humano
así que tuvo el humano también que
proyectar su percepción y decir pues yo
creo que hasta aquí yo creo que está
allí y la máquina aprendió eso como
prueba de que esto funcionó les mostré
el siguiente
el punto que ven es donde la máquina nos
dice dónde está la moneda o donde cree
que está la moneda
bien
a continuación hicimos unos cuantos
trucos de magia hoy solo les voy a poder
mostrar uno de los demás los pueden
encontrar online primero les voy a
enseñar un truco de magia para que lo
disfruten y luego les voy a enseñar el
mismo truco con lo que dio la máquina no
pestañea
la mano es más rápida que el ojo
la magia no está hecha para servirse
enlatadas y sin contexto de sopetón con
un vídeo de 7 segundos pero me pregunto
si miguelángel les ha engañado
a continuación veremos el mismo vídeo y
donde la máquina cree está la moneda a
ver si le podemos hacer un truco a la
máquina
todo pasado demasiado rápido y tiene que
ser así pues la magia no puede dejar
mucho tiempo la mente analítica para que
descubra cómo está sucediendo lo que
está sucediendo y esto nos lleva a un
punto también muy interesante sobre todo
nuestro trabajo con los magos y es que
no se trata tanto de que el mago nos
explique el truco para que luego los
neurocientíficos lo estudiemos y le
contemos al mago cómo funciona el truco
ellos llevan haciéndolo cientos de años
es más interesante ir en la otra
dirección
como puedes utilizar lo que saben los
magos para estudiar algo que realmente
fascinante y a veces da un poco de miedo
y es que tanto en el laboratorio como en
el teatro como fuera en la vida la mente
nos engaña casi todo el tiempo
bien pero me dirán que hay de la máquina
aprende o no aprende se le puede hacer
un truco no bueno aquí hay que ser
cautos con la inteligencia artificial en
primer lugar las máquinas propiamente
dicho no ven detectan
y además no atienden porque no tienen
libertad para mirar a un lado de la
imagen oa otra parte de la imagen además
yo sostengo que las máquinas no piensan
sino que calculan esto nos daría para
una larga conversación bien
el truco que le hacemos a la máquina en
realidad o así lo interpreto yo nos lo
hacemos a nosotros mismos a partir de
aquello que le hemos sabido enseñar a la
máquina de nuestra propia cognición
es algo así como un divertido y
fascinante juego de espejos fíjense el
científico le pide al mago que le haga
un truco al espectador que a su vez
enseña a la máquina para que de nuevo
ante el mago refleje y amplifica algunos
de nuestros procesos perceptuales y
cognitivos un juego de espejos
deformantes para entendernos mejor a
nosotros mismos
la magia nos recuerda algo que quizá ya
sabíamos pero habíamos olvidado sobre
todo cuando estamos tan tan tan ocupados
en nuestros laboratorios que la mente
como la vida es contingente chapucera
se equivoca se improvisa aprende
de forma y se deforma
las piezas no encajan y sin embargo la
vida sigue adelante
estudiar la mente humana desde la mente
humana es algo verdaderamente fascinante
pues nos sumerge en multitud de mundos
paralelos que a veces incluso se tocan
como neurocientífico en pleno siglo 21
me veo inmerso pues en el siguiente reto
el de cultivar una mente científica que
no por ello deja de ser una mente
participativa
solo el tiempo dirá si es verdaderamente
posible aún una ciencia humanista muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]